draw a rectangle with the same area but
with no side links the same as those of
the given rectangle
so here's our given rectangle and we
want to draw a rectangle with the same
area the same area so what is the area
of this rectangle
area is the amount of space
a shape
covers
so how much space or how many square
units
does this shape cover does our rectangle
cover
each of these is one square unit
so our rectangle covers one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight square units it has an area of
eight square units
so we wanna draw another rectangle that
also covers eight square units if it
covers eight square units then it has an
area of eight square units
but we can't just draw the identical
rectangle because we're also told that
it should have our rectangle should have
no
side lengths the same
so what are the side lengths of our
rectangle over here on the left it's one
unit long
and going across the top
is eight units long
this rectangle had eight square units
and they were broken up into one row of
eight
so we need to think of another way that
we can break up eight square units
one idea
would be two rows of four
because two rows of four would also
cover eight
so let's try that
let's create a rectangle here
two rows
of four
and we can just spread this out a little
bit so it covers the whole square units
and so this rectangle
also covers 1
six
seven
eight square units
so the given rectangle and our rectangle
have the same area because they cover
the same amount of space
but they have different side lengths
because our new rectangle
is
has a side length of 2 over here on the
side it's 2 units long
and going across the top is 4 units long
so it has new
side links
so here's one way that we could draw a
rectangle with the same area but
different side lengths